[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring the question
what's it like to sleep on a bus and
other stories from the road oh yeah
we've been on the road yeah we've been
traveling around doing shows and lots of
bunk bus bunk time for introspection I
had a horrifying experience which I'll
share a little bit later but I had some
really good experiences that I share
those as well changed my life as well as
the life of my children yeah so we've
been on the road on tour and then
attacked some time in North Carolina at
the end of my time and you came back
here and had a staycation so we'll get
into talking about that a little bit but
we do want to let you know that while we
are back temporarily we are going back
out on the road yes we're gonna keep
telling you about when we're going to be
on the road and you know what you should
go go on internets and look around and
all the fun that we had on our this this
last tour we've got there's a we're
gonna talk to him about it well there's
nothing photos though
yeah there's photos photo evidence of
the things that we did and how much fun
people had at the things that we were
doing starting September 4th September
4th the next leg of the tour begins
Houston Texas nollans
Birmingham Jacksonville Florida Tampa
Florida then we go to Las Vegas
October 19th November 20th Albuquerque
New Mexico then Phoenix Arizona
Sacramento California and Valley Center
California go to rhett and Link live.com
to get tickets and to clarify something
which we talked about this on our
Instagram one of those Instagram videos
that we did where we're eating tor food
but a lot we met somebody on the road
and we tend to meet people when we're in
these cities and they tend to say things
like oh I didn't know you were in town
that's why we continued talking about
the shows but then we met someone who
did know about the show but she was like
I don't have $300 and we were like what
are you talking about 300 ollars and I
think what she was doing and what a lot
of people are doing is if
just google rhett and Link concert
tickets well some sponsors everyday so
sponsored sites for where they're
reselling tickets are gonna come up and
you don't buy the tickets there go to
rhett and Link live.com to get the best
prices on tickets I think we've got
tickets starting at around $30 for these
upcoming shows so we're trying to make
it as affordable as possible so that
won't be an excuse if you don't know
about it that maybe that's our fault but
if you're paying a whole lot of money
for your tickets that might be your
fault if you're going to the wrong place
but the bus life was something that was
interesting which we'll talk about but
also the culinary lifestyle that we
assumed while on tour was I can't I
consequential I can't decide if it was
great or if it was horrible
it was great it was but he was a great
and horrible um we had this idea and if
you were you know if you happen to catch
an Instagram live like we're talking
like an hour before our show maybe a
little bit more sometimes we would sit
down and we would eat what you or at
least those of you who voted and
responded to our Instagram posts we ate
the two most popular signature dishes
from this most signature restaurant at
each city that we were in according to
you we pitted them against each other
and it turns out that those signature
dishes are not things like kale salads
no as you might imagine they're things
like you just increased the probability
of you having a heart attack by at least
2% like every time you eat something
nice that kind of meal I think by a
certain point in the tour we were eating
dishes that were just called cholesterol
yes okay we got a big styrofoam
clamshell open that thing up oh look
it's just cholesterol well literally one
of them was just fried cheese dip that
you dip in ranch dressing that was
pretty great and you know what it was
really good that was in Milwaukee that
what these curds yeah cheese curds
which it's no longer hurt no on y'all
Milwaukee one okay Milwaukee one the
food contest not only did they have
the best dish according to me I think
they had the best two dishes in court
according to me now I think you'd like
something they also had the custard I
mean the custard the hamburger and the
cheese curds Milwaukee knows what
they're doing when it comes to eating
cheeseburger and custard were from cops
and we would mean once you start eating
a cheeseburger not just any good though
a restaurant called cops k OPP yeah we
didn't we're not taking food from the
police right that is not what we don't
get Civic that is not what some civic if
we got that food from cops what are you
talking about from cops
yeah you're accepting food from well I
like I tried to pronounce lillies I
tried to emphasize the K in the
two-piece when I said it yeah and no one
except your own brains all that right
but I did see it k OPP is when you're
eating a cheeseburger that's as good as
that cheeseburger
you don't merely just taste the
cheeseburger you eat the whole
cheeseburger yeah I could even if you do
have a hole like a clamshell full of
curds over here and then you the way to
the custard is right next to it see I
made a curds and whey I mean I saw you
didn't even have to emphasize it I knew
that you were saying whe w wh ey whe wo
[Laughter]
[Music]
now speaking of tasting I'm I think I'm
still tasting what I had yesterday is my
last meal in North Carolina because the
thing that you got to do is you got to
come back to California and like go back
to a California diet and you probably
feel like clean and liked and youthful I
am at of fact I ate a vegan dinner last
night yeah see and I did not pull it my
farts well let's not talk about your
farts we do that enough I mean I don't
want to talk about him except to say
that like it ain't all peaches and cream
on this side of the table
okay well but but you but your body will
to us you had a week's worth of North
Carolina what I did is I did the tour
eating and then I went to North Carolina
and I was like I'm still on vacation and
I'm here in North Carolina
and I just kept on eating that way and
the the meal that is currently in my
stomach and I have actually like felt it
lurching what multiple times okay
you didn't kill it first I went my final
meal was cookout and let me tell you
what I got
I love cook yeah and I don't even know
if you know about this yet I don't I
don't know if you know about the all the
sides that are offered okay so in case
you didn't know cookout is a fast-food
hamburger place in the south that has
what makes it unusual it's not just the
fact that it's good food but the sides
that you can get other than fries are
basically just a ridiculous there are no
rules in the universe like they've
thrown all rules of what a side is to
the side because I got first of all I
didn't get a cheeseburger
I got a barbecue sandwich because I was
like you know what I've never had the
barbecue sandwich from cookout I've
never done I've always gotten it from
Smithfield's and we and we had one meal
left and I was like I haven't had a
barbecue sandwich yet Locke and Shepard
had never been to cookout or hardly knew
you were a horrible parent could not
remember the last time they went to
cookout mm-hmm
you know because Locke would have been
you know a lot younger you hit him on
the head every time you take him to cook
yeah so I I got a barbecue Simon in
black and then the side that I got of
course one of the sides was a corn dog
right because that's the side nuggets
can be assigned to get nuggets no the
other side was a chicken quesadilla but
you just got him you got may remains but
that's what makes it so crazy they got
chicken quesadilla they actually have
enchiladas as sides - we don't say that
word right quesadilla the other one
enchilada yeah it's not an inch it's an
inch and shilada it's an e not a no it
can't be talking to people about ways to
pronounce words man and shilada well you
know it's on gelato if you want to give
you say enchilada enchilada
enchilada honey right but go ahead we
know what you mean
oh well then you should paint me until
they tell me that I'm saying it wrong
I'll paint you so but I did but not
didn't get a the where I drew the line
is I didn't get a milkshake except over
40 different flavors of milkshakes
including one in July a watermelon
milkshake watermelon shake that has
pieces of watermelon in it that's only
served between July and August it's
great it's crazy it's crazy in it and so
nice to sell a place if you ever looked
through the window at them making all
that it's not like one person in there
just spinning around it's it's like a
one like a cartoon well I've seen
multiple people but there's only room
for one girl it I saw one girl and you
think you saw six girls but they were in
the space of one girl and you know how
some cookouts have like a table outside
of them yeah this cookout that was
somewhere between the beach and rdu that
had nothing it was just like we do not
expect you to stick around well yeah so
I just drove across the street to an
abandoned parking lot which there's so
much of it's like a just a base
abandoned building us and down east
there's just nothing there there's
nothing there between the beach and
Rolly there's nothing I I used to drive
that every week to see my in-laws so
it's like it was a post-apocalyptic type
of vibe to it
from time to time about the cookout and
the Bojack okay I'm tasting either a
barbecue sandwich or a corn dog or a
quesadilla
no particular order I can't believe they
have enchiladas I did not I couldn't I
wouldn't bet against I'd well I'm not
confirming that Lance we were with Lance
and Lacey and Lance told me he may have
meant quesadilla oh because when I got
there I saw quesadilla and just got it
the menus so big I didn't want to then
continue reading to see if they had
launched a lot how was how was the
barbecue sandwich solid very good ate
have sauce already on it they asked me
if I wanted slaw and Texas Pido and I
said well who do you think I am Texas
Pete huh yes
oh I would have gotten it but it was
very good steam bath not Texas Pete is
not a barbecue sauce and you know that
yeah because yeah well cause it's cut
it's it's good what do you mean does it
already have like vinegar
yeah it's got its got some sort of
vinegar sauce in the meat okay
do you know Bojangles is also now
serving a pulled pork sandwich it's on
the menu I didn't get that really and
I'm sorry it's I'm sorry I have to throw
somebody on the bus as quickly let me do
this
Atlantic Beach on Atlantic Beach which
is technically an outer bank
you know Emerald Isle in Atlanta Beach
they're all in this island well there's
a Bojangles on that island I was staying
on that island for a few days and we I
took Shepherd to Bojangles I haven't
been to Bojangles yet I get to Bojangles
at Atlantic Beach I get in line and you
know how they had like the only place in
the world that does the Bojangles is the
only place in the world that does the
line where you gotta go around like
you're getting ready to like go on a
ride okay
switches back oh not in the car you tell
my in the restaurant in the restaurant
there's a switchback yeah and then you
get up there and then that you order and
they say it into the microphone I'm just
wondering why they're still doing that
but if that's like an amusing part right
- it's like boggle up the first thing
that would threw me off is I'll get in
line and there's a there's a murmur
going through the line and it's that
they're out of dirty rice which I wanted
dirty rice I was gonna get dirty rice
and beans
Cajun pentose I love the fact that made
its way back through the line broke she
leaves you with girls go she would go
back to the mainland she would go to
Morrissey you know those kinds of things
are happening and then I'm like okay
well I don't have to get dirty rice 45
minutes later what is when I was
receiving my food at the 45 minutes
later this place
I love Bojangles but the one in Atlantic
Beach is so mismanaged that it is a
disgrace to the name of Bojangles it is
at because Locke and his cousins went
and they also had to wait 45 minutes at
a different time I realized that its
peak season but you weren't going to Joe
bangle there's there's 11 people in line
there were 11 people in line and some of
them were like three people together as
a party like we're not it wasn't 11
different groups it was like four
different groups
five minutes did you band together with
those people and like oh I'm not done
they're out of dirty rice I get up there
I order they're still out of dirty rice
at that point and I didn't even ask for
it they're out of honey mustard
taemi a post-apocalyptic then we get our
tea of course we got sweet tea Jesse
wanted she said bring me back an
unsweetened tea and then Shepherd now
are like we're gonna get sweet tea
because we're here when in Rome
we sit down and Shepherds late I think I
got mom's tea and he says let me taste
and he takes it notices no and then he
takes my suit dad these are all ensuite
I was like Shepherd this is just your
ten-year-old palate you know I mean let
me taste them they're all ensuite I'll
go back up and I'll say sorry dude you
put unsweet tea in these sweet teas he's
okay he's 45 minutes later that happened
in about seven minutes it wasn't too
long okay he fills him back up we go
back down and in shivers his dad they're
still unsweet I taste him he's right
they have not put any sugar in the sweet
tea I begin to see people who've already
waited 45 minutes for their meal getting
up and looking at their tea there's an
old man walking about he's like talking
to himself I was like the tea's not
sweet is it he was so he didn't even
hear me whose arm he goes up he gets his
tea and then there's a woman better
she's like y'all the tea's not sweet
this is bad I mean I this is good this
is we've got to put sugar in the tea
this is the start of a riot in North
Carolina there's a Bojangles
representative listening send help to
the one in Atlantic Beach man because
I'm not gonna go to it anymore
it's like yeah I didn't I don't want to
ruin it that food is so good I mean when
Bojangles runs out I don't worry right
or for honey mustard you need to airdrop
some supplies hey I believe airdrop a
manager in there I believe that it might
be actual sacrilege to serve sweet tea
that's not sweet
I think this people might go to hell me
to that I think that might be an
unforgivable sin right especially when
they're like no but this one is oh and
if you do it twice yes yes you go to the
third level of Hell sorry for that
little rant I didn't expect to do that
but I was really upset very upset
I would be afraid I mean with those
things happening at about angles I would
literally I would be like kids we got to
get out of here because something bad is
gonna happen like someone is gonna get
too upset and it's gonna be like they're
gonna be ripping like paper bags and I
don't know throwing tenders yeah Hey
well then we'll call him tenders but I
call them Supremes Supremes I also have
homestyle tenders yeah they're not hot
they don't have the spice and for the
cute children yeah I saw a full-grown
man order those notes for the week I
shook my head at that guy for the week
men and children oh man so you're you're
hurting I feel good now that I got that
out though you got that cook out in you
I got this v-type man it was it was like
it was beets and yams and they had this
big they had to think I'll barbecue it
was uh they had to think of barbecue it
was made out of mushrooms where is this
Cafe Gratitude
oh that place we talked about this place
and when you order off the menus its
adjectives like whole and complete and
serene and when you order you're
supposed to oral with the W or just hol
II put this in your hole we're having a
real hole
homonym of an episode here you know what
sometimes you gotta clarify there were
no cops there um it was it was it wasn't
what was I saying it oh yeah when you
order you say I am devoted yeah and then
you get a dog devotee
I have trouble I have trouble with that
system but I appreciate it I did it
I appreciate what it what it's trying to
do trying to give you gas and I'm not
talking about succeeding it's not at the
volume it's didn't flavor it schnitz
knit all right well I mean we got more
to talk about in terms of our tour so
let's switch gears to going back to the
tour but first years but first we want
to let you know that you can grab these
ear biscuits mugs
you can literally grab them there's
handle and also the figuratively
figuratively
grab them a mythical dot store when your
ears are drinking our mouths your lips
can be drinking from our mugs mythical
dot store dad still are we will did a
little I could have been cased a lot of
camera could have been breading could
have been a little hard breading on the
stick at the bottom of a corndog that
sticks with you awhile yeah not always
either oh you've never that stuff is the
best
listen you know what dick I would buy
sticks of just the hard crusty batter
you know what you can do is you can go
through the trash crusty sticks you can
go through the cookie out trash can
crusty sit and get out to the corndog
sticks
no but they don't people eat them in
their cars in at home nobody sticks
around but when you're driving out of
the parking lot you throw in I got to go
to the corndog castle for that refuse
bin mythical dot still are get it before
we get back into the story we do want to
let you know that this is the next to
last your biscuits before we're taking a
short summer break we're taking a three
week break is all right Kiko three weeks
without air biscuits
find another pod kit no don't find
another podcast listen to old ear
biscuits do that and you're in the three
weeks that we're not here don't get
hooked on anybody else now and then
we'll be back with more so next to last
we got one more next week in the three
week break and we'll be back I'll
quickly go through the rhythm of tour
you know because I think it can be
romanticized and there's many ways to do
it I mean we were we're spoiled on a
number of fronts first of all I just
want to brag about everybody who came
out to this leg of the tour and saw us
you guys were super supportive and and
welcoming and you know even I'm always
fascinated and we're so analytical when
it comes to anything we create or
anytime we perform like the moment we're
done putting something out into the
world or we come backstage after another
we're immediately assessing how well it
went in it it never fails to surprise me
how
different audiences are different well
how all audiences are a little bit
different the things that as a whole day
that that resonate with them some
audiences are really they like to cheer
some audiences like to laugh some
audiences do both some like to talk some
like to talk to us and I think we there
are cues that we give that welcomed that
and sometimes it's sort of a show we
kind of we're a little more open than
other times and we made it a point to
try a few new songs and the banter in
between like we that's our moment to see
if we can create something new every
single time give or take but we're I you
know we talked about how when comedians
are musicians too or a lot of times they
have to win over the audience and we
never have to do that because the people
who show up or dedicated mythical beasts
so there's this comfort level and so
like I said we're spoiled on that front
we also have a bus that we travel in now
what when when the bus goes a really
long distance in between shows we do fly
but we finally realized it's a for most
of the tourm at the gallery we didn't do
this but we started to realize towards
the end that hey we can we can sleep on
the bus this can actually be fun this
might be the best part of the whole
thing
maybe not four six seven young man well
considering that the bunks are six six
yeah in length I'm so but we are spoiled
to have a bus that has 90 bunks and then
it pulls the trailer with merch and
stuff behind it and so us and the crew
we basically traveled on the bus the
whole time also brought my kids Lily and
Lincoln along with us on this leg of the
tour but just having a bus like that not
having to like sleep in a van or like
out of a crappy hotel or something well
it was we're spoiled and I don't know if
this is necessarily the case with you
know like a band that would be going
around I mean I guess they do stop
somewhere to shower but we do got that
you got that corndog crust coming up we
do also basically
we as soon as the show's over well we
have our meet and greet we usually don't
get out of a town and start you know the
bus doesn't start rolling until after
midnight
maybe 12:30 and then we roll into the
next town we most of us go to sleep
immediately or within an hour or so and
then you don't set an alarm or anything
you just wake up well you said we roll
into town and then most of us go to
sleep
no once the bus starts moving we go to
sleep and then it's driving to the place
Oh a roll out of town roll out of town
yes yeah so like an hour after we leave
everybody's pretty much asleep and so
then you don't send an alarm you just
wake up it's some you know you went to
bet you go to bed that late if you're
gonna bet at 1:00 1:30 you know most
people are gonna wake up at 9:10 I'm
gonna wake up at 10:00 or 11:00 and then
we realize the bus is no longer moving
and that everyone has vacated the bus
except for me and my children
usually the Neels of the last off the
bus I was the last off the bus one time
but most of the time you guys are I get
up and I see all your shoes are still
there I'm like oh they're still here
but then there's Gary our tour manager
has created a basically a map or like a
very simple set of directions for like
this is how you get to the hotel like
here's your hotel key you do have a
hotel because you're gonna go there and
basically shower and we would just
basically shower and then we'd have a
couple of hours go out some and go out
and eat lunch and then maybe you know
walk around or if if their scooters we
would scoot around town for a couple of
hours before we have to get back for
soundcheck and signing posters for the
meeting greeting all that I'll tell ya
Denver is a good place to scooter
very good they got this river there
that's like got Rapids all in it and
then there's like it's fancy all the
paths they got around this river yeah
that was a that's a Denver was the
scooter scooting highlight yeah scooting
capital the world you might say scooter
lowlight was probably Omaha Omaha I
would say I mean more for Britain than
for us because man he took a tumble what
I saw the whole thing in slow motion now
let me just say
right before Britain had an in his
incident on the sample I was thinking
about we're in Omaha and there there's
also a giant river is it that was er II
rivers I would that way yeah coming
through
Omaha and like we're going all around
and scooting up and down these paths and
there's this little like park next to
like the ConAgra campus there and we're
like going around this pond and I was
thinking after we've been out for like
an hour and a half I was like its kind
of surprised that no one has fallen yet
and I actually in my mind was like kind
of surprised that like one of the kids
and when I say one of the kids I kind of
throw Britain Britain is more a kid then
he where he's 19 we could we could be
his dad Yeah right I mean he's only five
years older than Lincoln and I was I'm
surprised that one of them hasn't fallen
on these scooters yet and literally
three minutes later I'm voodooed him I'm
going I didn't say anything did you stab
a doll I'm going over this bridge in
this part is sort of arched bridge and
we get to the in Britain's in front of
me and it was just this change in the
surface there's a little bump sometimes
all it takes is a little bump as a whole
because I hit it - yeah we did use a
drop off it was a drop off and then it
bump on the other side because it was
like this depressed area of like bricks
and he hit it and I saw him begin to
lose control and then he overcorrected
and then it came back then he
overcorrected again and then he flew off
of the scooter at full speed and did a
pretty athletic move to like fall down
and roll into a backflip and land in the
grass but I could see on his face
immediately that he was shaken all I
could see is I was coming over the
bridge horizon where his feet in the air
oh you saw that yeah and then he was he
was rolling tore up his elbow and is in
one of his hands and it's like hold are
many of your moneymakers right guitarist
and he had a show I mean we had a show
then well he had a show the next night
right because we didn't have a show that
night now thankfully Jenna who is here
was also there at the time because the
link and I just proceeded to laugh and
make fun of breath
hahaha as he sat there in shock and what
we knew he wasn't dead it wasn't really
her he wasn't actively bleeding there
wasn't anything broke he was actively
bleed he was actively in fact he got
blood all over his pants yeah he was
shaken he got pee got a little pale he
was a little bit in shock but we knew
that he wasn't permanently injured so we
laughed and that's what guys do man and
in the Jenna came in and was thinking
straight and strategically what was that
magic fluid you started pouring on his
arm like contact solution it was just
water oh it's just water she used her go
now she sacrificed her her glasses cloth
oh it was the cloth and that's about the
what when you said I I'm gonna use my
glasses cleaner I thought all of that
liquid up until this moment I thought
she was pouring glasses clinking I was
like no it's like MacGyver but that's
also poison its I thought was alcohol no
I think that I think then which is why I
was just sitting on the side laughing
because Who am I - oh I could've who
knows what I would have poured in his
wound right hey let me pee on it man I
think when you get stung by some asphalt
you got to pee on it yeah just like a
jellyfish but probably could he
convinced it no it'd have been funny
Jenna took care of him and we we did all
scoot back to a place where we could
drop the scooters off because we were
outside of the scooter off loading area
that we couldn't with the app would not
accept us to just stop where we were but
he ended up being okay he looked kind of
cool playing the next night with a large
bandage yeah around his elbow he got
some sympathy points or whatever but
anyway in terms of the schedule yeah we
typically do something for a couple
hours usually no one would get hurt
and then we'd show up at the venue we do
a soundcheck we'd signed posters for the
meet-and-greet and then we just sit
backstage we do we'd eat our food and
there's a so it'd end up being like
three hours of just kind of sitting
around backstage and then doing the show
and the whole thing starts over again
but you would really get into the rhythm
of like I can't wait to get back to the
and I know that was Lily's favorite part
there's something about climbing on this
bus and like at some points the bunks
were three high and at some points they
were too high when they're three high
you you cannot sit up in your bunk you
just gotta roll in and roll out like a
log roll but we got the two they gave me
and you I still get the two hi
yeah and some of the crew but the
youngsters got the three high and I
there is something like cozy it's like a
cozy hideout and you lay down in the
thing and you pull your curtain closed
and you velcro it and then you didn't
even take your pants off mmm-hmm take
whatever you got on off if you want to I
wasn't naked I had the really
comfortable pants though that I did I
left on because like it's almost like a
blanket in and of itself there's a
little light in there and then you can
set up your earphones and you can listen
to some like a playlist to help you
sleep or you can just go to sleep to the
murmur and the rustle of the bus in that
that was a lot of fun but I started
playing well every night I would go to
sleep with I downloaded this playlist on
Spotify called deep sleep and I would
listen to that thing and it would it was
like eight or nine hours of just ambient
sleep inducing and then some pianos over
topic and what headphones are you
employing for this my bose
noise-canceling in-ear headphones not a
sponsor right because you can't use the
air pods because they were dried out
eventually I actually did use air pots
some time and they would just fall out
of my ears and I'd wake up in the middle
of life searching for an air pop because
I'd be chewing anxious that I'd lost it
forever
so does this preclude you from sleeping
on your side I would roll all over and
sometimes the whole chord would just
tangler on my waistline but about ear
pain when you I'm a yeah loose if size
sleeper I'm a back sleeper and it but I
did sleep on my side summon there is
inner ear pain where it like you're
smashing I said I can't listen to things
in the ears that's not the worst thing
about it though
but I will tell you what is
and that's when you're listening to an
eight-hour playlist of just instrumental
ambient music which is great like send
you into a deep stupor which you only do
this on while traveling you don't do
this at home I do not and I'm laying
there sleeping and then all of a sudden
a woman says to me don't leave me and I
woke up terrified and I I like look
around there's no woman right there's no
there's no there's nobody talking on
this deep sleep playlist much less
singing this is instrumental and I'm
like I was I dreamt that a woman said
don't leave me I went back to sleep
was it Christie's voice but I was kind
of it was it was it was more dramatic
than that it was a dramatic it was a
dramatic I don't know it was it it was a
lot of need in it it was it was it was
very disconcerting and I don't remember
dreaming anything but I I was able to go
back to sleep and then I went deep again
nothing wake up next day fine
fast-forward to the next night same
routine and go to sleep have been asleep
for a few hours
and then all of a sudden the woman don't
leave me she returned and this time I
woke up I'm like okay I know is there a
ghost in here I don't I don't know
what's going on and I'm like it's the
frickin playlist in the middle of a
nine-hour playlist that's just
instrumental there is one snap sound
snippet in the middle of a song where a
woman says don't leave me and that is
terrifying
it's a Spotify you got to remove that
from the playlist in a matter of fact I
found it because the the third time I
was like you know what when this happens
I'm gonna take a screenshot and I'm
gonna remember so I can't remember where
this is it's just an easter egg man it's
an easter egg that people who commit
fully to the playlist experience
lonna Johnson breathing star yeah it's
Alana
[Music]
I kind of I like to feel needed and
wanted not when you're in a deep sleep
man it's like you have to what I'm not
leaving you girl I'm laying here asleep
I'm not you freak me out man
so then I'd hey you know I told the
people like to show that night and then
there was a good runner about don't
leave me yeah it really worked it did
it's the type of stuff you live for you
know getting scared
I thought crap scare what I was thinking
was gonna happen is the music was gonna
drop out completely and someone was
gonna say don't leave me because that
would that would that would wake me up
for sure so that was a low light but I
would say a highlight of the tour
besides again like I said we're so
spoiled by the but it was just a great
audience reception it was great to
connect with so many mythical beasts and
to get even more of an idea of what
makes them tick and what makes them
laugh you know it it it turned out to be
very special for me because Lilly and
Lincoln were there
I didn't think Lilly was gonna be able
to come but then the fact that they both
were able to come now I well I mean we
should say that Locke was gonna come but
then because it's got yeah he had like
five basketball games in that in that 11
day period so it would have been he
would have left his boys hanging yeah he
couldn't he couldn't do it yeah but he
was obviously invited and there was
there was a chance he may come and then
and then hopefully in the future he'll
be able to do something like that
because it was so special for me and my
kids and of course Lando's two young
shepherds probably too young because
they they provide to fend for themselves
the kids had to fend for themselves but
you know it just it it wasn't I realized
that it was such a sweet and special
time for me and Lillian Lincoln
afterward when I started to reflect on
the fact that really the only time that
we spend that much time together like
every waking hour for 10 days straight
the only time we do that is like if we
go on a family vacation right you know
and a family vacation is a totally
different vibe than being on tour
because everybody
in a different mode when vacation is
happening but when we were on tour it's
like we're in tour mode so like we're
working and we're doing things and I
think they they kind of rose to the
challenge I wouldn't call it a challenge
but they kind of rose to the occasion of
hey we're we're part of the crew you
know they they rolled some posters and
they would hand them out at the meet and
greets they didn't roll posters every
night sorry Jenna but you know they felt
that they were treated as equals you
know and I could definitely see that in
their take away as they like reported
back to Christy and Lando when we got
back home how much they enjoyed it and
they talked about to her life I I was
hopeful but I I didn't want to be too
hopeful I you know me I think of this
pert when they get back they're gonna
have this perfect idea of what tour was
and it's gonna be the most influential
thing in their entire lives so I did you
know I didn't want to go into full
dadlink mode with my expectations but I
was so I was pleasantly surprised that
it meant so much to them and they said
they had a great time and I think it's
just spending that amount of time
together you really get in again when
you're not in vacation mode it was a
great opportunity for us to get to know
each other because you have you I was
able to observe him interacting with the
other members of the crew and like okay
when do they choose to pipe up and what
do they choose to say and what are their
perspectives on things it's something
that I don't have the benefit of that
often and I actually thought about I got
a little jealous of Christy over the
years who as difficult and demanding as
it as it was for her to home-school the
kids for all those years they've been a
public school for this is their third
year now but in the same with Jesse it's
like I got to see a little bit of a side
of them that I think Christy and I'm
guessing Jesse got to see of our kids
that we don't get to see as much when
it's not like you're constantly with
them you know and then at the end of 11
days you don't then you're good you
don't have to do anymore Yeah right like
they're good but you know it just turned
out to be a very special time
you know what they said that they enjoy
getting to know you more in kind of a
work mode there unprompted they were
like you know what I actually have a
different view of Rhett and I'm like and
I told him about my vacation theory and
I extended I was like yeah a lot of
times when you see red it's like it's in
family or if we do vacations together
it's in that type of mode and it was
just like the thing that I think it was
Lincoln who said he was like maybe it
was Lily she was like you know what you
guys I thought it was cool to get to see
you guys actually enjoy hanging out with
each other I was like well have you ever
watched our show but I think she knows
that that's the show and but it's not a
show I think is what she said it's like
I enjoyed you guys enjoying each other
well I think I yeah I didn't know what I
thought about him my first thought when
they were gonna go I was like oh no
we're gonna have to like worry about
them and yeah not be able to get into
places because they're too young and etc
etc but I my thought was to my strip
clubs again yeah yeah yeah my my I've
never been in a strip club just for the
remind my thought was no judgment if you
have eight listen let's change this up
yeah well I'm just why you tell my strip
club I didn't say it didn't say anything
about that I'm sorry I was talking about
bars you know we're 18 and up or 21 and
up you know some there's some
establishments where children are not
allowed right right so but I actually
think that having and I think that
Britain also contributed to this as well
yeah having younger people there like
definitely significantly changes the
dynamic because we have a tendency to
just be in work mode like all the time
now sure well let's go get on these
scooters and you know run around with
like we would do if it was just me and
you and it has been just me and you and
gone out and and just scooted around or
whatever but I think that something
about having kids there it lightens the
atmosphere a little bit it's not that we
don't know how to have fun with each
other it's just that we have so many
things going on that there's at any
moment we could stop and start talking
about some you know work-related thing
or some project and even if it's a
creative thing we'll do it in a very
serious manner and so I think that they
actually kind of like change the dynamic
the group dynamic and they're you know
there's being kids just being silly yeah
and kind of having this vibe of wanting
them to have a good time so electing to
do more things to have a good time
versus just maybe I'll just sit in a
hotel or let's talk about work and I you
know I do want to say I really do
appreciate the way that you included
them and you know on the it was
unfortunate but totally understandable
that lock wasn't able to come but the
fact that you were able to extend
yourself to include them as much as they
without me asking they noticed and I
really appreciated that too I thought
that was very gracious and yeah I think
it was I think fun was had by everyone
except for maybe Britain's elbow and I
think it's cool just in conclusion that
you know a lot of people ask us what are
your kids think about what you do and it
it was just it meant a lot to me that
they thought it was fun and cool to be a
part of something their dad was doing
you know it was there weren't any I
roles it was like hey this is yeah and
ice is cool and that idea I do want you
know and if lot can't go and the next
couple years or whatever then hopefully
Shepherd will be able to like I I do
want them to be able to experience it
because yeah it's like yeah there's a
different feel than just saying I'm
gonna come on set when you have a guess
that I'm interested or something like
that there's a there's a it's a
different it's a different thing you
know I'm glad they'll see we had the
opportunity to give them that gift and I
know I I believe that they'll remember
that trip forever and that's what I
hoped for so that was my highlight but I
want I want to hear about your vacation
too because we haven't had a chance to
talk yes so we got through with the tour
I I'd flew directly from Minneapolis to
the beach
in North Carolina to spend time with my
wife's family or her parents and her
sister and husband and kids and we were
going to spend a couple of days in one
location in a couple of days in a few
days in another location so you may if
you followed me on Instagram shout out
the red MC on Instagram very dynamic
Instagram account from time to time you
may have seen my what went down on the
day of July 4th I don't know if you saw
any other the only thing I saw was you
looking for horses which you can leave
for Instagram after that I was like ok
oh you missed you missed well that was
just the warm-up story you didn't see
the firework show ah brother ok so I've
talked about this before I've talked
about how my father-in-law used to like
get fire were like together he would
produce the show ie he would finance the
show and then I would go to executive
pretty and I would go down to South
Carolina and buy the fireworks and then
spend all day like wiring them together
with extra fuses and stuff and like
creating like as crazy of an amateur
firework show as you can get away with
right well illegally in North Carolina
yeah well it's illegal in the sense that
going 62 and a 55 is or 64 and a 55 is
because okay no yeah on July 4 turn a
blind eye they turn a blind eye in fact
I've had the cops
and when I say cops in this setting I
mean Co PS drive-by while I was in the
process of lighting a crap-ton of
firework on you know lighting them and
they just kind of like not as just like
yeah oh it's fortunately so you're
American I'm American
oh man I I'll have to show you I've
still got video of some of it because we
were renting a one of my well we were
staying at one of my farlow all those
houses
he's got down there they have like a you
know property company that's got
different houses that you can rent so we
kind of like reserved one of them and it
was one that was on the sound that had a
very long dock that went out into the
sand I was like this is perfect we're
gonna take all the fireworks out onto
the dock and light them oh no but I was
like I'm not gonna take all day to get
the extra fuse I was like just get me a
powerful lighter that you know is it a
windproof like torch kind of lighter and
then we'll just figure it out in the
moment you know just take some stuff out
there and light it and you know trying
some stuff together you're not used to
all that prep anymore here you don't
work hard anymore work and also I had
Locke and then his two teenage cousins
and and then my brother-in-law so we had
a lot of help to like get the things out
on the dock and and first of all I don't
remember exactly how much money we spent
on fireworks ten years ago which is the
last time I did this but my
father-in-law went a little bit nuts
with the amount of stuff that he bought
like he can sent one of his employees
down to South Carolina and the guy came
back and like though he had like a twin
cab or like quad cab truck or whatever
and like the whole back seat was just
stacked to the ceiling with fireworks
like this guy had been in an accident
and there was a little spark oh my gosh
he would have like created a crater he
wasn't a smoker on that day but anyway
we set these things off and the cool
thing about setting the fireworks off in
the sound is you've got all these people
watching from of course we've got my
family that's up there on the dock on
the deck watching from the house and
then you've got everyone else that just
come out to the back of their houses
along the sound on both sides to watch
all the fireworks happening oh so by
about this if you warn them about know
by about the second round of lighting a
couple of these like you know they
basically come in these like boxes of
fireworks that have like it's just a box
with a fuse on it and it has got a bunch
of mortars like built into it so I'm
gonna sometimes this 10 shot sometimes
it's 40 shots right anywhere in between
and basically he's its own little show
yeah we had like 50 of the
Thanks haha so there were times when we
were lining up like six and twisting two
fuses together and three of us would
light him at the same time and then run
and by the time we did like the second
round of these things we had an audience
like people like people can tell when
you've done it you've gotten through
with a little bit yeah one brown right
it's like last firework goes off and
then it gets quiet and then all of a
sudden all these people from wider and
wider radius would go ah and then we
just we had an audience that's good
that's not like a rebel yell and now and
then there's other people doing
fireworks at other houses within by
about the fourth or first of all they
were like fifteen rounds that we did but
by like the third or fourth round one
guy yells out you win it's not like
that's all I needed to hear it's funny
and yeah that is what that is the what
that's specifically what you were after
right you win not that's awesome like he
said exactly what you wanted he you know
I told I I told my father-in-law I was
like and when I went when the guy said
all the things I was like we are going
to have the best firework show we're
gonna win firework in noise area you
know not professional that is yeah it's
funny you talk about the Woo's because
last year we were watching fireworks and
from our house like from our bedroom
deck we just happened it through some
trees see the fireworks display of the
local high school and I'm like we
realized that we ran upstairs and we
started this year the kids watched them
but we were hanging out downstairs with
some friends and we didn't you seen one
fire at you seen them all I'm sorry I'm
sorry that that's my attitude but last
year yeah you guys seemed we were so
elated because they fire we started
going off and it was me and Kristin the
kids up there and all of a sudden behind
me I just hear and I turn around and
Christie is like what I'm from Canton
yeah
okay then that's almost down to the
beach where you were is where she grew
up and it's like that's a I I mean I
that's just an instinctive southern
thing when you see something on fire in
this guy well yeah well here's the thing
it's this is the reason is not only is
it better than a professional show
because you're the one in control of it
but like you're so close to it I'm gonna
win safe I'm gonna show this is this is
lock filming us light lighting one of
the room okay this is all in Instagram
but he's filming he's filming or the
wrong part of it he's filming the equity
is z-bo i critiqued it what I'll show
you I'll show you when I filmed it even
when he films in fireworks he's filming
just below the fog that if the is the
pier catching on fire well we'll get to
that in a second
oh and I'll show you one that I filmed
this is a little this is not there you
can see a flame down there right you see
that flame well it's one of the things I
didn't put this on Instagram because I
was a little embarrassed about this the
zooming is that's a lot bit now when I
filmed ran by guys a bunch of rednecks
out there with a shirt so that's one set
these are huge these are massive you've
never seen this before you never been
present for one of these huh I mean like
it's a legit firework show you thought I
was talking like little bottle rockets I
didn't know it was that big no it's and
listen you're right next to it like it's
in fact we did we have you getting
sprayed we had five left over and we
took them to the other beach house which
is up on the intercoastal waterway like
up on the Neuse River okay and there's
another dock we take it out on that and
I lit like six that night this is
Saturday night so July 7th I guess just
a couple nights ago and technically I
think they're illegal by that point oh
yeah they're not turn a blind eye but we
had more yeah you're like going out on a
dock so as to for the view oh you're not
doing that so if it catches on fire the
whole dock will just burn into the water
and then it's safe well it does so that
does help because I'll get back to how
he had to handle that fire in a second
there was one where the wind was coming
back towards us and something they don't
always go as high as they should and
where's one that blew up and then it
blows up into a bunch of different
pieces then it blows up again and
smaller explosions I swear there was one
that happened where the second small
explosion I'm the one closest to the
action cuz I light it then I kind of go
down the stairs because this dock had
like two levels and then I'm kind of
watching it one came I swear that I was
getting hit with the little sparks it's
not safe as I said on my Instagram I
gave it my wife made me do a disclaimer
she was like you need to do a disclaimer
so people don't do this and I said my
wife wants me to give you a disclaimer
do not do this unless you're a redneck
as cool as this looks and it's fun as
much fun as I'm have you will hurt
yourself if you're not a redneck but so
fire time so Jesse first of all she says
do you have a fire extinguisher like
right before we're getting ready to do
this and I'm like no and I was like
we're doing it in the over the water and
she's like you need to have a fire
extinguisher and I was like okay so what
they had one at this house like
underneath the sink and what happens
after these things go off as you as you
can see it's so hot
that sometimes they just end up catching
fire after that all the stuffs gone and
so I'm looking at that and me and Chris
are like trying to figure out what to do
so we ran and got a fire extinguisher
but they they basically expended it was
one of the fire extinguishers like we
used in the t-shirt war where it was the
powder oh it runs out real fast and then
we had more fires happening to the
nandus we had to send the boys the fire
brigade to the house to get buckets and
we took sound water and started throwing
it all over the fireworks and I will say
that one of them got was on fire before
the water got there and I had to throw
it into the water but we did get Isaiah
to go retrieve it get it go to the next
dock the damp yeah
trash yeah so everything's good
still good we still good yeah we're
still good man you make me nervous
no in it I'm not there I understand this
I do understand that it's not responding
carry on it's not responsive one of
these rednecks has got to carry on but
you know what you gotta have a little
fun every once in a while man you gotta
celebrate
but it was so hot I mean I I forget how
hot it is well we'll find out next week
hotter than the fourth of July
you'll be back in North Carolina for
something that will tell you about this
novel related but we're going we're
going out there next week that's right
it's unbelievably hot I walked outside
my freaking sunglasses fogged up like I
actually don't remember that happening
growing up in North Jersey they've just
fogged up completely because I was going
from AC but your face your California
face gets hotter as adjusted no it's not
adjusted so when you go back to North
Carolina your California face just it's
like oh my gosh my face is so hot I got
to get rid of it and it pushes it on to
the glasses and they follow oh that's
very nice but if you live there all the
time it's like oh you know you learn how
to not fog up your glasses and it rained
your face learns that it rained every
day but it didn't help you didn't care
because you were already wet like you
cannot just you just go outside and you
wet I mean you immediately start
sweating from everywhere that's why you
you said a bunch of rednecks and not
having shirts on but you very quickly
learn I might as well not have a shirt
on you might as well be naked because
any clothes that you have just
immediately stick to you like I put
jeans on to get back on the plane coming
back yesterday and I just had jeans on
do basically walks in my car and I was
like I remember now while we always wore
shorts like we were we mean you would go
to work in shorts I remember there was a
point I actually remember quarts and
flip-flops I remember when we were
filming the documentary looking for miss
Locklear we had a conversation she wore
jeans because we didn't want to look
like a couple of dumbasses walking
around and short rice we were so hot
that was the first time we made a
conscious choice to only wear pants did
you feel like a dumbass wearing short
shorts a little bit but I just like I
just did quickly man yeah it's not you
shouldn't feel that way but we do know
something about shorts just makes you
seem like and I don't I do not in you
what does it make you seem like a bear
leg bare legged man I don't know but if
they if they're pleated and you can tuck
your shirt into it then your back that's
not the kind that I had you're in total
dick you're just you're just did dad it
gets so hot and it gets super hot in
California as well it gets to be it'll
be like 110 towards the end of the
summer here but it's never so hot that
you actually feel like if I gotta get
into shorts like it really doesn't know
it's because the humidity's differently
do you feel like there is a way for you
to feel cool and I don't mean
temperature-wise I mean like trendy
insurance shorts I don't see any I don't
see an option that I think for us that's
a good question well I just don't think
I don't think we can pull off shorts I
think there are shorts out there that
are trendy shorts I just don't have them
and I don't know what constitutes a
trendy short I think they were a little
bit shorter than those shorts that I
wear probably get more interesting
patterns a little shorter and thank you
I got to have like a tank top on and
maybe a visor none of those things
can you pull off I don't think I can't
either yeah well we shot I can't I think
I can pull off shorts well I think I can
pull off shorts I don't think you can
you see my legs I'm not commenting
commenting on your legs I'm just saying
just the exposed nature of your leg I
have a lot of leg yeah I mean your
thighs at eye level to some people yeah
I have a lot of leg I do a couple of
other notable things I drove around a
car that was an advertisement for my
father-in-law's dentist dentistry not a
car that I had it was wrapped in an ad
oh did you get paid no that's actually
better it was wrapped in an ad that had
my deceased grandmother in-law on it her
face
yes what yeah she was in one of the ads
what what what do you mean in one of the
ads how many ads were on the car well it
was like the whole thing was wrapped in
your in your dead grandmother in law
yeah well she reached she just passed
like a few months ago was she what
position was she it's just her face
she's smiling and showing your beautiful
teeth really mm-hmm
on every side of the car just she's on
one side and there's another group of
people she just like her and some other
people on one side and there's other
people on the other side so I was a
while I was a driving ad yes that means
a free visa free transportation I drove
it everywhere drove it all over the
place yeah that's that's I did not get
paid for it though and I thought it
might be I thought about asking and when
you hopped out what were you wearing
shorts exactly well this is I didn't you
were the total package brother no every
morning I woke up I put on shorts and
nothing else no shoes no shirt and I
remained that way for all of the day oh
I don't I don't blame you I'm just
saying and if it was not good for the
brand and if it wasn't improper I
wouldn't have had shorts on you know I'm
saying like you it's so hot that there's
no difference between the inside of your
body and the outside of your butt no I'm
just saying you don't need to protect it
in any way we're people coming up to you
asking you about the business oh yeah
really I made stuff up but they didn't
believe you because you were in shorts
and you were shirtless so I think you
kind of negated whose knee who's that
shirtless man is he is that the
shirtless dentist it's so hot I
understand why does it work she does his
work out here there's a plumber called
the smell good plumber a shirtless
Dennis the shredder this shirt
the shorted dentist this is a
technically I only had shorts on
but the shirtless dentist is something
that I mean you can just you're sitting
in the chair laid back all of a sudden
you got armpit in your face yeah he's
reaching over trying to get a utensil
let me tell you that armpit stinks I
know it does I don't I would put
deodorant on in the morning but I might
as well didn't because see you see the
slippery slope you're on you just start
stinking you just you stink constantly I
mean I didn't you hear it gets long any
like baïdir'
I will say I had a dream about what when
I was when I was on vacation I had a
dream oh now this is really crazy I
don't understand what happened I think I
may have seen some like news report
because I had a dream where like the
Saudi Crown Prince was flying a very
small open hatch plane like an old-style
plane but he was pulling behind him
another plane that was pulling behind it
another plane yes that was pulling
behind it a boat a plane train boat
caboose that was pulling behind another
boat that was very very large like a
cruise ship style boat and then on and
on and on and was off in the a all in
the air he was in the air even the boat
was in the where were you you were in
the dentist I was I was in a some
vantage point where I could see all this
from the ground I felt like I was on a
cliff and he was going by because I feel
like I was I level with it but he was
over the ocean okay you were I loved and
here's what I thought in the dream
that's like man I got to remember the
details of this for ear biscuits in the
drink but I wasn't thinking about in the
dream I was thinking about it as if I've
got to remember this moment where the
crown prince flew his crazy plane tray
you believe it you
where you believed you were living the
moment and so ironically now I'm telling
you about seeing that crown prince in
his plane train but I'm telling you
about it one layer removed because it
was a dream about telling you about it
but now I'm telling you about the dream
in which I thought of telling you about
the plane train Wow that's weird
I think you shouldn't told us I think
you should have kept it in dreamland I
think you should email the Saudi prince
but man you just wait when we go back
it's gonna be hot hey I'm only packing
shorts now can you get on a plane
nothing but shorts is it like no shirt
no shoes no service thanks you have to
wear a shirt do you go yes
I've seen no signs there's not Saiyans
but people shirtless no problem people
routinely get kicked off of planes in
fact can their shirt people routinely
get kicked off of planes
usually women for having overly
revealing clothes now I'm not saying I
agree with this policy but just last
week there was a report of a woman who
just had like a strapless tank top thing
I don't know a tube top and she got
asked to leave the freaking plane and it
wasn't even really risque and I so if
they do that there's and I don't know if
it's an airplane if it's a like a
airline policy but yeah you have to wear
a shirt you can't if you just take your
shirt off in the middle of the flight
they'll ask you to put it back on sir
could you please put your shirt back on
he'll say that and then if you say it's
so hot but it's so hot officer that's
not gonna work I don't you think they
would I don't know if they would turn
the plane around from the flight deck
we're gonna have to take a u-turn go
back to order you crew got a man or not
put a shirt on I don't think that would
happen you know what about a mesh tank
top you see nipple yeah the straps are
low and the nipples there on either side
of them in there my nipples your nipples
yeah well for reasons that I'm still
beginning to try to unravel male nipples
and female nipples
are perceived differently I mean one's
acceptable on Instagram and one isn't so
I would have to say that your Megan
Instagram is the modicum of morality
your mesh nipples will probably get by
on the plane but it matched their beside
mesh oh that oh then mesh is on the
inside of the nipples yeah that's what
you said I put my tank top on backwards
I think I think they would they were
there would be a discussion about
whether or not to approach you right by
there when they're trying to sort out
the almonds and the Chex Mix they'd be
like you see you see seat 13b yeah busy
the further back your plane is like if
you're in the second plane or the third
plane being full pulled by the second
plane beam you're going back to the play
then the less you can wear so if you're
in that second boat you can be naked
I think the Saudi Crown Prince has
pretty specific standards with the coin
it comes to dress though I thought
there's a high dollar boat I think that
I'm in not trying to get into that into
those watery I don't think nipples are
it's been a civic podcast when you told
me I immediately pictured a plane towing
a plane towing a plane in the air
towing a boat that was on the groove in
the air towing another boat which was
much bigger as you said but that one's
in the water none of it was in the water
I think I was in the water at one time
last ones in the water I think it
started out in the water right they were
all where they all boats start in the
water well nothing starting to factory
then they're launched into the water
was it a water plane no it was a little
single-engine open fete open top
whatever you by daddy principle goggles
yeah I don't you know how a race car
that's pretty much all that happened to
me all my vacation okay that's worth
mentioning well I hate a missed it I was
at home doing nothing wasn't even
looking at your Instagram I don't know
what I was doing did you how did you
occupy yourself that's it in different
places did you clean things oh yeah I
would I'd sit in different places and
eat different things that were usually
vegan
I'm not going vegan or anything I'm just
trying to counteract what had happened
on tour
it felt good to do that crap am I
supposed to have a wreck in effect no I
I got I got a risk I'm so relieved I was
I'm not ready it's not ready me this is
a little bit of a cheat because I'm
gonna wreck something that I wrecked on
Twitter which maybe lower the value of
this recommendation but I will expand a
recommendation I will expand the
recommendation as so as to make it this
somewhat value point guy you may have
seen that I tweeted about Blake crouches
new book recursion Blake Crouch is a guy
leave Eastern North Carolina and doesn't
live there anymore
she is he's shirtless on his book jacket
no yeah he sure did and the first books
I ever read by him he wrote a trilogy
called the wayward Pines trilogy the
first book his wayward Pines and then
there's two more and I read all those
that was also made into a show and then
he wrote another book called dark matter
wouldn't run another book what is he an
author called dark matter which is all
wayward Pines is this very it's all kind
of like sci-fi psychological thriller
kind of situation if you're into that
kind of thing and I am dark matter was
all about parallel universes a
multiverse and navigating those and just
super thoughtful book and when he goes
into you know sort of the science behind
these very crazy concepts in the way
that he explores them it can get a
little squirrely sometimes when you're
trying to approach things that there is
some sort of scientific understanding
established about these things but then
you're trying to write a fictional book
about them and I just feel like he
strikes a really good balance and then
recursion is his latest book which is
all about the nature of memory and some
very sci-fi stuff that is based on some
current understanding of the way memory
works but taking that to a very sort of
unexpected place anyway
highly recommend Blake Crouch in general
his
latest book you could start with any of
these his latest book is recursion
I recommend it if you're into sort of a
wild ride for your mind what are you
doing over there
nothing I'm listening I'm sorry there
was a tangle in my thing and I was just
letting you do you think I'll fix this
afterward recursion you say a wild ride
for your mind that's very very
entertaining a wild mind ride take a
ride on Blake crouches mind did you get
it untied you didn't get anything I said
I'd do it later all right guys thanks
for hanging out with us listening at us
and we'll speak at you again next week
hashtag air biscuits we look at those we
look at those to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]